hey I'm Josh wolf and I think the NFL
should embrace weed and here are the top
420 reasons reason number 72 because
come on man wouldn't that be crazy
that's the word because come on man Hill
[Music]
[Laughter]
reason number 118 a puff-puff pass for a
testicle you know what anything I just
figured out it keeps getting more
crooked because every time I hit the
record button my moves at camp my eyes
totally in the red zone right now
ha ha ha reason number 172 quarterback
tweek
[Applause]
I don't know means I just have it
written down reason number 1 2 2 1 2 2
that's the first time I ever said it the
way I saw it
reason number 1 22 because the players
can use those phones on the sidelines to
order pizza yeah same time reason number
42 less Raiders fans getting in fights
in the bleachers reason number 381 if
you eat enough edibles every game is
technically a fantasy game boo it's the
stupid I wish I had more saliva
[Music]
I'm just tea hey but I'm doing it like
this I don't care oh my god
what so this is it man can you cut some
of this [ __ ] together I'm so sorry
yeah reason number 211 concession stand
money are you kidding me right now
60,000 people with the munchies let him
smoke some weed what's the problem
reason number 275 who doesn't want to
see a mascot hi
[Music]
because the players are gonna do it
anyway so just embrace it see stop
getting them into trouble you dumb
[ __ ] yeah reason number 420
they literally already call it the Super
Bowl I mean you don't even really have
to change that but a good stuff here
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]